I think the backstory of this movie is
so interesting because you and Andy knew
each other well before there was ever
gonna be a movie about your family's
story so I wonder if you can just
explain how we got to the point where
that came came to be part of the
relationship sure well I being a
producer always looking for stories it
took me a bit of time to realize that I
was sitting on rather an amazing story
the story of my own parents and I had
long wanted to create a movie but first
of all it was dependent on finding the
right writer and I saw a play called
shadow lands by Bill Nicholson and I
thought that is exactly the tone that I
think the movie should have and I
developed it for quite a long time with
him partly because when I asked him to
do it and I told him the story he said
he'd love to do it on the condition that
I didn't pay him until and unless the
film happened which is a great result
and so for six or seven years we
developed it together whenever he was
free from his other assignments and I
was free and we got it to a certain
point and at that point to my great joy
Andy Serkis and I had already formed a
company called The Imaginarium
and Andy read the script and to my huge
joy he said he asked me if he could
direct it so I thought yeah definitely
no problem now Andy you've had people
know you for such a long time for great
acting an innovative acting and so much
within that side of the business but had
juror had you always had an interest in
directing what you know how far back
does that go and it actually goes back a
very very long way before I became an
actress studied visual arts so I always
was very much in touch with trying to
tell stories visually before even before
I became an actor and over the course of
you know 25 30 years during my as my
acting career was taking off I started
to make short films and got involved of
course after meeting Peter Jackson
working on Lord of the Rings the whole
performance capture
this venture started so I started to
direct performance capture for video
games and and other projects and then
Peter asked me to direct the second unit
for the Hobbit for the Hobbit trilogy
which was about the time that Jonathan
Ive formed The Imaginarium and then
finally as we were laying out our stall
of things that we want to make and form
this performance capture studio and
production entity at the same time you
know it was very much with an idea that
Jonathan would produce films that I
would direct and and this this falls
into that category although and it's
become my directorial debut this film
but in actual fact we'd already started
working on another production the jungle
book which which we'd shot and was in
post-production then there was this
incredible window of opportunity when
the most incredible two actors were
available and that one of them is
sitting on my left Andrew how did this
first cross your radar and was there a
specific aspect of it that you just
tapped into you said I have to do this
it's so magical I read this script and
it was unlike anything I've ever read
they bill Nicholson and somehow managed
to take this life this larger-than-life
existence and somehow contain it in a
120 page script and it didn't and it
felt like I don't know if L allegorical
it felt like it was it was it was bigger
if it just felt bigger than a whole life
somehow they managed in the how Bill
wrote it he managed to find all of the
God the cosmic mysterious connection
that these two people had and their
connection to the world it went beyond
to human beings and I just sobbed I just
kind of read read this thing and sobbed
and and and laughed and sobbed and
laughed and you know interchangeably and
sometimes both at the same time and I I
kind of saw a template of how to
if i thought well god i want my life to
feel like this so maybe maybe by
apprenticing to robin and i can rub off
on me and then i and I spoke to Andy and
that was just a wonderful conversation
he put he put any fears or kind of
concerns I had at rest and they had
dinner with Jonathan and in this city we
went to a wonderful restaurant called
animal I don't know if you've been but
I'd recommend it if you're not
vegetarian and I I met I met an
embodiment of these two people I met I
met what these two magical people
created and they created an another
magical person and I thought well a few
months with this person would be a
lovely time and what an honour if he
ultimately wants me to play his father
what an honor I want to ask Jonathan and
Andy if you can tell us about the other
key element of the film who's not here
Claire Foy I think it's amazing that you
know now it's I think now it's like it's
obvious in the cool choice if you can
get Claire Foy to do anything after the
crown you know you do it but this was
before anyone had seen any of that so
how did you guys realize that she was
right for for this part pick her out of
a lot of other people I'm sure would
have wanted to do it well I think the
first time I sort of saw her I've had I
mean Andy's actually worked with her
before and knew her well personally and
knew her work probably better than me I
went to some awards ceremony and the
very first trailer for the crown was
shown because somebody was getting some
award had worked on it and I looked at
Claire playing the Queen and my mother
is a not unrealistic extraordinary
so we then very quickly met her and it
was very clear to both of us that you
know not only is she extraordinary
extraordinary person and an amazing
actress but that she had some of the
things in common with my mother
beauty bravery living in the moment
which is I think a critical shared thing
not looking back not looking for just
being there bang bang plunk in the
moment which is
something we'd all like to learn to be I
think Andrea I want to ask you I know
from just various things I've read that
there was a lot of work that went into
this before the cameras ever started
rolling for you obviously this is you
know you don't see too many people with
with polio and what that comes with
these days so if you can just talk about
the the sort of preparation that you did
which I believe extended even to dental
related items which you can I'll leave
that to you to explain yeah I mean as
soon as it was all go and and Jonathan
decided and and he decided that this was
the right thing I just kind of I just
you know it was like going to university
for Robin cabindish Studies and I had
about two and a half months of getting
to know him by osmosis that's kind of my
favorite part of the acting process is
that that preparation period where
there's no obligation to get anywhere
where you just get to swim around and
spend time in the in the library as it
were and so with that came time with
Jonathan time with Andy and time with
people who are living currently on
ventilation ventilators on external
ventilators doctors my brother's a
doctor in London he introduced me to a
couple of patients of his and the
remarkable thing about that one of the
remarkable things about that is that
every single patient I spoke to had some
connection to Robin and Diana whether it
was a direct connection or whether they
were just aware that their lives had
been changed by these two people's
bravery arguably idiocy and kind of you
know the diving headfirst into you know
putting Robin in in in danger in order
to fully live his life so that was
remarkable and then of course as the
technical challenges and that I worked
closely with Andy and and Jonathan about
that I had one recording we had run one
recording of your father later on in his
life where the croak and his voice
became very
so I we decided well let's work
backwards and we so we start with a
clearer voice and then we end up in that
very kind of deteriorated place and then
the rhythm of the breathing machine
obviously that very unnatural consistent
rhythm kind of adhering to that creating
that for myself was really really
interesting then of course you know
being paralyzed you you have all these
bodily impulses and the only part that
can move is my face so that was
wonderful I got to be very
unselfconscious of my face for once in
my life doing a film you know okay we
kind of broke all the rules of what you
know film acting is in a way it's like
you know less is more actually you know
for Robin Moore was more he wanted you
to know what he was thinking and feeling
because and the only way he could do
that you know he he couldn't put his arm
on you he couldn't he couldn't give you
a hug week but he could he could he
could do it with his um you know his
soul through his eyes and through his
face so anyway that's just scratching
the surface but it was a true privilege
to work on this role and it continues to
be to talk about Robin in this way